in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Jerrod
and a Jolin Jolin joy Lin join Leah yeah
I was working so hard to get Gerard's
name right I messed up
welcome guys good to have you where you
from great to be here we're currently
transitioning from Hilo Hawaii to
Petaluma California I'm in the military
I'm transferring oh well thank you for
your service and thank you ma'am we have
a trip from Hilo Hawaii to Nashville yes
goodness gracious
Wow and all to do your debt free scream
huh yeah we're visiting family in
Maryland in Florida and this is a little
halfway point we decide that we even
think about this one you know months ago
that we wanted to stop by here make this
part of our vacation that's fun well
we're honored you did we're very honored
and so how much debt of you two paid off
about $85,000 yay I love it how long did
that take about 18 months way to go
very cool and range of income during
that time how about ninety three
thousand dollars combined okay very cool
and obviously you're in the military
what are you doing the military I'm a
food specialist in the Coast Guard
uh-huh cool and what do you do Julia um
I work at a university on the University
of Hawaii at Hilo
oh cool and what do you do um mainly
administration stuff in the School of
Nursing okay Nate well good to have you
mm-hm thanks for being here very cool
what kind of debt was the $85,000
everything yet credit cards timeshares
car loans and student loans anything you
like them all you did them all yes
that's amazing so what happened eighteen
months ago they got you guys on fire cuz
I mean you busted through this hard yeah
well we got started because the
chaplains always offered you know FPU on
base everything that and I thought about
it and I was like I don't know and
didn't some my co-workers and they were
paying off all this debt and things like
this like and I'm gonna podcast guys so
the guy out download a couple Dave
Ramsey podcasts and give it a try and
then I was hooked and it was after that
I was just getting her hooked so how'd
you do that I came home one day in the
CSO how are you doing I saw better not
deserve she's like what does that mean
then I thought about Dave Ramsey and the
FPU and you know how the things we could
do if we're debt-free and you know she
was on board at that point oh very cool
so you sat down then and decided you're
gonna lay out the budget and do the game
plan yes and so so tell me how that
first process went what was the first
things you did well when we created the
budget we we didn't want to cut anything
out but we knew it was necessary so we
just we had bought the Dave Ramsey
financial piece at home for a military
addition and we created the budget from
the back of the book from there and then
just started writing it out and we
figured out how much we needed to pay
off to meet our deadline and we did it
okay so what was the deadlines anything
in particular um it would be before we
would transfer on the back to the
mainland so we wanted to make sure we
got it done you want to be clear by this
date yes looking very cool very cool
good so that got you on fire I mean cuz
you guys you you didn't want to kind of
thing you cut a bond
did you sell anything well no we didn't
sell anything
um actually 50,000 of it was I'm an
inheritance my mom recently passed away
oh um once we received that we knew we
had to put it towards the debt so that
we could stay on track okay well you're
not only on track you boomed it I mean
this is awesome very very well done
very proud of you good job so when
people hear that you've paid off eighty
five thousand dollars in debt what do
you tell them the secret is that I say
the secret is just get started you know
I'm a big procrastinator and I just need
it once I got started it got the ball
rolling you know you start seeing
results right away you know it's not a
get-rich-quick thing it's a get results
quick you know you start seeing results
right away that's a good line
you pay off their first debt and do you
like man I'm saying you know the ball
starts rolling and it's it's easy at
that point very cool what about you joy
what do you say the key is um just being
in communication with each other um you
know I like to go shopping I like Target
and that was one of the best stores on
the island
so just you know just trying to stay on
budget and make sure you're on the same
page J would always say how long do you
want to be in debt and so that kind of
helped put it in perspective for me to
you know keep my spending in check in
get everything paid off so when you're
doing the big 18 month budget 18 months
worth of budgets I mean you're leaning
in on this thing was the biggest budget
fight you had
well it wasn't necessarily a fight but
we have the opportunity to go to Kauai
we were stationed on the Big Island and
we wanted to go to quite a free marriage
retreat all we had to do was pay for
airfare and we made the decision a
compromise that we wouldn't go so that
we could get out of debt faster and then
once we were out of debt that we would
be able to go on a bigger vacation and
stay longer so that was our compromise
live like no one else so later you can
live like no one else yes very cool well
congratulations you guys are very proud
of you again thanks for your service my
pleasure thank you good to have you back
stateside yes mainland side or harbor
you say that very cool congratulations
all right Jared and joy Lin Hilo Hawaii
$85,000 paid off in 18 months count it
down let's hear a debt free scream 3 2 1
love it love it love it where to go you
guys man that's incredible
yes hey it feels it feels amazing to be
completely free absolutely amazing hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
and so you have to break the cycle you
have to flip this thing on its head and
make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind